hi my name's Rob Miles welcome to my
channel it seems pretty likely that
sooner or later we'll develop General
artificial intelligence that is to say a
software system that's able to reason
about the world in general and take
actions in the World At Large we don't
know how to do that yet but before we
figure it out it would be good to know
for sure that any such system we create
would be safe would be positive would be
beneficial to
humanity it's not as easy as it sounds
on this channel we'll talk about machine
learning and artificial intelligence
we'll look at some of the problems of AI
safety and some of the work being done
right now on those problems if that kind
of thing sounds interesting to you hit
the Subscribe button um you may also
want to hit the little bell if you want
to be notified when new videos come out
uh and more importantly if you know
anyone who you think might be interested
in this kind of thing uh send them a
link yeah that's it for now new videos
coming soon watch this
space
perfect perfect yeah that's the take use
that one